fewer than 40 hours of oxygen remaining
so could this be a rescue mission
impossible well the remains of a Titanic
where some are speculated in the sub
could be stuck rests 12 and a half
thousand feet beneath the surface of the
Atlantic at that depth no light from the
Sun reaches the ocean floor it's pitch
black temperatures are near freezing
around 0 to 3 degrees Celsius water
pressure is 380 times greater than on
land that's the equivalent of being
trapped under 100 Story Tower made of
lead and to illustrate just how deep it
is twelve and a half thousand feet is
about nine Empire State Building stacked
on top of each other well joining me now
are Explorer and friend of British
businessman Hamish Harding uh Yannick
Mickelson retired U.S Navy submarine
Captain David Markey and Dr Michael yeen
who's a journalist who became the first
TV correspondent in the history to
report from the wreck of the Titanic
well welcome to all of you
um Jenny let me let me start with you
Yannick if I may obviously a
devastatingly difficult time for you and
everybody who knows any of the these
five people on board how are you feeling
about this because obviously Hamish
great Explorer done many very risky
things in his time but this as time goes
on does look to be potentially like a
real tragedy unfairly
it's looking Bleak I'm terrified for the
worst news now it's
um I have a little bit of Hope but they
have all the odds against them at this
point and it will be a miracle if they
can recover the summary they're
submersible with a crew that's alive
what kind of man is Hamish for those who
don't know him
is larger than life he loves exploration
he's been to space he's been to the
deepest point of the planet he's been to
the South Pole and he's also mentored me
a lot in my career as a Explorer and
this is why I'm living close to the
North Pole to train to be a polar
Explorer and survive in a Polar climate
there are videos of I think Hamish and
others talking about this this vessel
the submersible the thing that struck me
was that for people who were so wealthy
it doesn't seem a particularly
sophisticated piece of Machinery that
the risks are pretty high actually
something was to go wrong would that be
a fair assessment
I myself haven't seen this submersible
but with any Expedition there's a large
amount of risk involved if you want to
be the first person to do something
today on planet Earth or in space you
have to accept risk because if it was
easy it wouldn't have been done
um David you've been a retired United
States Navy submarine Captain so an
expert in this field I want to play a
little bit of what I'm just talking
about a little clip of some of the
people who are on board talking before
about it including Hamish
an experimental submersible vessel that
has not been approved or certified by
any regulatory body and could result in
physical injury disability emotional
trauma or death
where do I sign I couldn't help noticing
how many pieces of this sub seemed
improvised we can use these
off-the-shelf components I got these
from uh Camper World We Run the whole
thing with this game controller
[Music]
so today
they're sort of been quite jokey about
it obviously this is now a very serious
situation
um did they underestimate perhaps the
dangers or is that just always part of
the risk you think of this kind of
expedition
no I think you could do a better job
mitigating the risk we know from a long
history of operating submarines in the
Royal Navy the American Navy I've been
underwater for 87 continuous days what
it takes to keep a submarating operating
safely underwater we have first of all
starts with the design and the building
of the submarine we track a bolt from
when it was manufactured and say it's
chromium magnesium alloy two when it's
installed on the submarine every step of
the way because we want to make sure
that the exact right Bolt but the right
material is installed in a right bolt
hole this all costs money and then when
we operate the submarine if we were in
Port for a while we don't just go out
and submerge in deep water and see how
it goes we we test everything at the
pier then we go deliberately 100 feet
200 feet 300 feet walk around with
flashlights checking things it is
daunting and this is why these
submarines cost so much money so I
admire people pushing the boundaries and
throughout the human race these people
have contributed a lot
hey man some risk is unavoidable but I
think you should try and do everything
you can to minimize avoidable risk what
David what do you think is the most
likely scenario that's happened here
well uh for the families and friends
prepare yourself for bad news
the communications abruptly ended
and the submarine has not shown up on
the surface so to me that signifies the
likely that the crew has been
incapacitated it could be simply that
the batteries die but in this case I
would expect to hear someone banging a
wrench for example against the titanium
and bells of the submarine but we're not
hearing anything so I worry that there's
something there could have been a fire
on board they could have somehow
depleted their oxygen way early and not
realize that they could have flooded
somehow A fitting corroded and ruptured
and water came in and when you're that
deep you said 380 times the pressure at
air that's just the number it's hard to
conceive how that happens like this the
water would come in so fast they
wouldn't experience anything they would
be crushed they would be drowned they'd
be asphyxiated and they would feel no
pain what is the difference between a
submarine and a submersible
a submarine has a big motor a big engine
and a propeller that drives it out of
port so it's on its own leaves Port uh
leaves Norfolk goes out to sea drives a
Thousand Mile submerges and and operates
a submersible has small maneuvering
propellers so it's towed out to the side
of the Titanic it's released by the
mother ship it can drive down hover
around the wreck uses those propellers
because there's currents down there so
it uses those propellers to make sure it
doesn't get swept into the Rack or
entangled in the wreck and then when
when they're done sightseeing and the
time's up then they come back up to the
surface
well thank you for the expert uh
guidance too because I think a lot of
people are a little bit confused Dr
Michael you know better than most the
difference you've been honest
submersible in 2000 you went down there
for ABC News you were the first TV
correspondent in history to report from
the wreck of the Titanic at the bottom
of the ocean we've got a little clip of
this I think
as we approach the stern of the ship
we're suddenly caught up in a strong
underwater current that pushes us
towards one of the gigantic 21 ton
propellers oh my God look at the size of
these things oh my gosh so are we stuck
or what
as this graphic shows we appear to be
somehow wedged beneath the wreck of the
stern
a scary moment for you uh does this
bring back pretty awful memories of what
happened to you and what could have
happened
yeah
I'm feeling pretty sick right now
and uh
agree with that Lieutenant the two
things that um
come out at me right now is the loss of
communications because even when we were
stuck down there our pilot so it was a
former Russian Nick pilot was piloting
our three-man sub much smaller than the
one that's currently in its situation
and uh he was able to communicate with
the surface ship the research vessel the
academic kelvish on the surface I
couldn't understand what they were
saying it was all in Russian but
nevertheless and then the second thing
that stands out to me Pierce is
um as a lieutenant pointed out if it had
just been a failure of communications
then that pilot would have brought that
thing up to the surface immediately so I
mean uh we can speculate endlessly I
hate doing it because lives are at stake
utterly hopeless it's not easy to get
out of there I can see the emotion there
in you that this is obviously and and
indeed also for you uh Yani um because
Dr Michael I guess
you must have had a moment when you were
in a similar situation where you thought
you may not get out of it right
yeah more than a moment uh the better
part of an hour and uh being a scientist
of course I'm a professional Problem
Solver so my first instinct was number
one to hope nobody in the cabin would
panic because we had been told uh by the
captain of our ship before we went down
that he told us a story a true story of
a gentleman who has found himself in
that situation and in his Panic went for
the escape hatch to open it up it's
right above your head and of course that
was the end of it because it's the cap
as the lieutenant said the pressure's
down there enormous uh I filed a story
for 2020 and then Good Morning America
and just to illustrate how this powerful
the pressure is down there we took some
styrofoam cups and the cup came back
about that small and all the air had
been squeezed out of it from the
pressure down there that brings it home
it's a very hostile environment very
cold very high pressure
um so uh yes for the better part of an
hour I kept thinking well how can we get
out of this there was another Russian
sub in the vicinity and I thought
perhaps it could tell us out but of
course it's not feasible it's not AAA
comes to you out of the month
um and I just ran through the checklist
of things in my mind and I finally came
to that moment that brick wall that
utter sense of uh hopelessness and the
words that came into my mind were this
is how it's going to end for you and you
have to understand I've been to the
North Pole the South Pole I've covered
the Persian Gulf War for 14 years ABC
news I've been all over the world I've
Been In Harm's Way everywhere but those
words came into my mind and I'll never
forget it this is how it's going to end
for you and I thought of my wife Laura
thought I'd never see her again just by
the grace of God Victor and his skill
managed to weasel her way out of that
big propeller it's a big propeller our
ship was very small you have to
understand it's a huge propeller our
ship is small in comparison we just got
trapped in the blaze but if it weren't
for Victor's hero efforts of I wouldn't
be here today to tell you about this but
it's just terrible it makes me sick well
incredibly emotive uh description there
from someone who really does know what
they may I mean look you had a miracle
Escape we can only hope and pray that
something may turn up here we don't know
obviously what's happened until we know
for sure there's hope and they they
would still have enough oxygen left if
indeed they're still alive and we can
only hope and pray that does happen and
Yannick for you and for everyone who's a
friend a family member our hearts go out
to all of you and we just hope and pray
that there is a miraculous ending to
this but thank you all very much indeed
for joining me I appreciate it
thank you peers